[Music]  hey you kids  it's dinner time my favorite nighttime  why does nobody come in through the  front door dearest mother and father we  will not be attending this evening's  ritual mastication  what they're both growing up so fast  they wouldn't be caught  dead with their parents  wait a minute what i've got a dish  it's hideous it's monstrous  it's the old adam's camper  for some family bonding what huh we are  going  on a road trip this is cruel even for  you  let's roll  [Music]  this trip will bring the atoms closer  than ever before  let's make some memories  [Music]  my music's so loud  it's just us and the wonderful sound of  [Music]  silence  now that's great  here he is  i still don't understand the word that  guy says  where's katie he and it hit the catnip  pretty hard last night  [Music]  so